大家好,我是學長
很多人會學長說我的咖啡想要香一點
或是酸一點或是淺一點
我可以怎麼做呢?
這時候我們就可以來思考一下
那關於香氣的部分
其實很多時候跟悶蒸是有正相關的
所以你悶蒸做得越好
通常正常來說的香氣越好
那悶蒸要注意的部分
其實就是你的布水
因為悶蒸我的粉層有時候有些是厚一點
有些是薄一點
我一定要注意給水的時候
粉層一定要均勻的吃水
粉多的地方要吃比較多的水
粉少的地方吃少一點的水
不然的話你的香氣就很分散
所以覺得不香了
那如果你給水已經做得很好的話
你可以利用水溫的增高
或是燜蒸時間的增加
例如說我燜蒸90度
我對到92度93度
我的香氣的上氧成分就會增加了
或是燜蒸時間原本是30秒
我在粉塵不塌陷的前置之下
只要45秒
就是到一分鐘
都對你的香氣和累積是有幫助的
那就是關於香的部分
那對於酸的部分呢
其實愉悅的果酸
會讓你的咖啡喝起來很活潑那你可以多多利用濾泡法這樣的手法可以讓你的酸子可以很清涼喝起來很迷人特殊風味非常的清楚
那同時間呢
如果你想要調整一下研磨度
可以調粗一點點
或者是我的水溫稍微降一點點
它對於整體的配水
都比較容易往前段走
你的果酸就比較清楚的波厚
以及低段
前面段的給水
你可以水放大一點
都對應酸質有放鬆的
那第三個問題就是關於甜質的部分
要怎麼增加
那其實甜質你可以多利用浸泡的手法
它對於甜質的脆脂是很有幫助的
那同時間你的研磨度也可以調細一點點
因為細的研磨度對甜質這種大分子的東西
是比較容易出來的
或者是水溫稍微調高一點
有很多道理
以及偏後段的給水
可以給小一點點
讓我的粉跟水有更多的浸泡時間
它就會有更多甜質出來
以上關於濾泡法、浸泡法以及一些參數的相關點的東西
如果大家有興趣的話,可以參加學長最新的課程
就是咖啡萃取版的課
裡面有很詳細的描述囉